yes sir the toll of this talk is from
health care dot hospital import data
signs and a short introduction where are
we from we're from Amsterdam the both of
us
we work at the Netherlands Cancer
Institute which was founded in 1913 on
the left was the first hospital on the
same as canals and they started out with
a medical staff of just a few guys still
smoking cigarettes and cigars back then
and nowadays we have a very modern
Hospital and also a combined Research
Institute so the hospital is called
Antony van Leeuwenhoek and the Research
Institute is called the Netherlands
Cancer Institute so it's a dedicated
Hospital / Research Institute only for
oncology all right
so and we are going to tell you about a
data science project we just recently
started in our Hospital and more
specifically in the department of
radiotherapy let me first walk you
through the people who are let's say
involved in this data science project so
on the Left we have said we call it the
clinic they it's comprised of the
medical doctors the nurses medical
technologists and medical physicists on
the right we have research and
development we have that's a principle
investigators postdocs PhD students and
software developers and what I was going
through my slides I found I forgot one
very important group of people which is
the patient group who probably they
don't like it but they provide us with
the data we hope to do something useful
with okay so who are we both Pavlov's
and I are physicists we did our PhD in
purpose did his PhD in Monte Carlo
simulations of small the symmetry fields
and I have a background in theoretical
hydrogen high energy physics but we both
have I say let's say we both like
hospitals I don't know why and we switch
to medical physics physics and once we
were in hospital we switched to data
science were not we're not data
scientists as everyone is nowadays but
we're still physicists but we do like
data and I think our let's say our
overall ambition is to extract meaning
from all the data we have that's all the
clinical data we have and to assist with
this to assist the
season makers in their clinical
decision-making all right now like I
said we are from the Department of
radiotherapy I'm not sure if you're all
familiar with what radiotherapy is it's
the use of ionizing radiation to kill a
tumor cell basically and let me walk you
to the radiotherapy change so this is
what the let's say the workflow in a
radiotherapy Department looks like in
the upper right for you guys it's the
consultation so that's where the patient
meets for the first time with the doctor
then this patient goes to the process of
diagnosis and I also highlighted what
kind of data we gather from these
several steps at consultation let's say
it's it's medical data lab results or
written data oral data whatever
diagnosis we enter into the mat at the
imaging face so you get a CT scan or an
MRI scan or a PET CT or whatnot and you
have lab results etc after diagnosis you
go to the so-called tumor and organ
delineation where let's say there's more
medical imaging and processes performed
on these medical images from medical
imaging you go to the treatment planning
where we do simulations of what kind of
treatment this patients should get once
the simulation is done you go to the
actual treatment and then you go to the
outcome of the treatment and along these
steps there's more get data get more lab
results medical imaging data etc etc all
right well our abyssion is to assist the
decision makers in all these steps with
making more informed decisions to better
the treatment for the patient of course
so let me walk you through the several
decisions which are made in every single
step of this clinical workflow now let's
say at the first step at the
consultation it's a very basic decision
we need to make which needs to be made
where a doctor is there a problem
right then the patient goes to diagnosis
and and the tube and the doctor decides
well is there a tumor next step in human
organ delineation so if there is a tumor
where is this tumor and the technician
then steps in and if tries to find out
where the organs relative to the tumor
once these decisions are made you pass
on to treatment planning then the
physicist steps in and it goes on to
decide how should we treat this patient
the knowledge of where the tumor and
organs are sitting etcetera well then
you go to the treatment itself and then
detect another a technician steps in he
performs the actual treatment and he or
she decides well has the patient changes
etc and after the actual treatment the
doctor decides okay was this treatment
effective do we need to change anything
alright so this seems to be there's a
lot of room to make data-driven
decisions in this whole clinical
workflow so you would expect there's a
huge I'd say at least enthusiasm for AI
or machine learning methods in in
medical healthcare but you are
understanding there's little to no
practical implementation of data-driven
methods but there is a lot of research
and I want to try to tell you why
they're still let's say in congruence
between these two between you speak
between these two groups who all who all
share the same goal to improve treatment
for patients with cancer so the clinic
we have not allowed we don't have many
data study people workflows often change
so that's hard for you for your let's
say your for structured data gathering
and people don't trust much in models
there still work we've been doing this
all our lives and it's been working so
why should we change anything why you
should you tell me that I should do
something better you physicists in
research we have a lot of data different
people of course we like like data we
physicists but there's a different
incentive in research you want to
publish publish or perish right and
physicists or research they tend to like
original ideas and it don't care that
much about implementation so if it's
interesting enough for researcher you
will pursue it but he will not care
about the actual implementation so
there's sort of a discrepancy between
these three groups between these two
groups and more so there are also this
restrictions on the data we actually
gather so I phrased these as questions
and you might think about them yourself
now so for example is in-house developed
software and medical device can I share
my code with other hospitals or
companies who is allowed to work with my
page with patient data and can data
scientists actually work with medical
data now these questions are not
answered but they are trying they're
going to be answered this is for the gel
data protection regulation this is laid
down by the European government European
Union sorry - let's say - to - to
formulate a good answer to all these
questions in medical data because their
privacy laws etc etc all right this is a
small sidestep what but it's a data I'm
actually talking about I'm basically
talking about medical imaging data and
in the 1980s there was the syllabus
whole lot of mess of different imaging
standards and they came up with a format
and it's called DICOM it's called the
digital imaging and communications in
medicine and it's the international
standard of medical imaging data and it
includes CT images MRI images etc etc
there's a nice Python library we use
called pie diagram to handle all these
objects but the thing is to work with
the data is very difficult to query this
whole assembly there because it's a
graph based data so it works it's a
little bit more cumbersome all right
what's the amount of data we're talking
about Oh a Yankee eye we all metal
scansion good sorry we treat on average
5,000 patients annually among all tumor
size so I mean this move I mean tumor
different tumor locations her neck
breast long etc on average to 250
patients per site so that would you
would say that's a lot of data it is but
the problem is there's a big variation
in the image acquisition and imaging
modality in patient data so patients
might start with a CT scan but the
doctor decides only he or she needs a
more scan or should I should complement
it with a PET CT and the difference per
patient might also differ per doctor
what he or she thinks is more relevant
for this patient so this it's difficult
to gather a say a nice formalized data
set now we want to assist the decision
makers in their clinical decision
process so where should we start
ideally you would start with a
consultation and predict the outcome but
we're missing a lot of data to do this
we don't have a reliable outcome data
for example so what we did we went
backwards to this clinical workflow in
decided to worse could we as physicist
slash data scientists have the biggest
impact now in treatment there's little
room to do anything okay so we go back
one step treatment planning still not we
room to make improvements you come to
tumour an organ delineation and it's
highlighted in green so this is what
we're going to talk about of course we
did not focus on diagnosis because
that's say there's also an
interdepartmental stuff you need to work
with radiology in radiotherapy and it
might you have to deal with a lot more
people so it's also more cumbersome so
we decided to focus our attention on
tumor and organ delineation purpose will
tell you all about the details of this
project and it is also very general but
we decided to stick to Hera neck cancer
specifically it doesn't it only accounts
for let's say five percent of all cancer
cases worldwide but the outcome is poor
so there's a lot of room for improvement
as you all know had a neck cancer is
caused by the fun things in life smoking
drinking oral sex
sorry kind of do anything about it and
we decided to focus our attention on the
so called the radiation of the survivor
II glance because you know Hellenic
radiotherapy treatment they also receive
radiation dose and if they receive too
much though she will get very serious
side effects later on they are cold for
example xerostomia on this stage which
means a dry your saliva events won't
work anymore you will get difficulty in
swallowing which will seriously hinder
your quality of life
alright so we're going to talk about the
organ delineation it's also called
contouring and what this means in
practice is that condition he annotate
CT medical images everyday to specify
the organ shape and location that's
called an organ contour and this is a
very difficult time-consuming and still
very manual process often biased by
personal opinion people might differ
about what the correct and good contour
should be and it's not always clear
after contouring is corrections or if
it's okay to proceed for treatment all
right I hope I said the general stage
for what we want to do what we intend to
do and now my colleague Pavlos will tell
you more about the specifics of our
project yeah
speaking of where Patrick finished so
yeah so we focused on the contouring of
Oregon delineations and this for example
would be a CT image of a patient before
it goes to radiation treatment and most
of the contours have been contoured by
Somaly still it's a very manual process
even though there's a lot of software
offering auto contouring possibilities
they our main hypothesis though here is
the following that a body structure
should in on average respects a
morphological characteristics and that's
what we're tapping it so whatever
somebody did in the now it's probably
gonna be very similar what happened in
the past and machine learning an image
contouring is not a new thing it's a big
thing in in research world there's a lot
of albums that are focused mostly in the
auto contouring part this mean the
algorithm predicts what where the organ
is and how does it look like this is a
competitive to the expert approach
basically meaning that in few years from
now the experts gonna be out of job
maybe or a more collaborative approach
the expert is an anomaly detection
system which we are focusing mostly on
this and this because the algorithm then
in this case we just want him to flag a
case that was very anomalous based on
previous historical data so we thought
this would be a good way to convince
also clinicians to be on our side since
it's not very competitive to their work
to begin with and before I get into more
the details of this specific problem in
general what is an anomaly and this is
an ill-defined concept in regardless of
the industry there are always we don't
really know what we're talking about our
normal here in this case we're actually
talking about medical error that's where
what a catch and however some things to
keep in mind if you have some data
points here and I ask you what were the
anomalies probably these four points
would be outliers but in a global
context this might not be true so this
is things to keep in mind especially
when you have
a large population of patient data and
the other thing is context matters maybe
you've seen this picture obviously the
red fish is the anomaly but what was the
question was it the question really if
the fish is going against the flow so
context matters on the problems that you
you said to solve so if we cannot define
well what is an anomaly then what is a
Couture contour normally as Patrick
explained about a little bit about the
delineations and this is the case of a
parotid gland that patrick already gave
you some insight of what it is and this
is something that even experts cannot
really tell you and that's important
because we're now going to be able to
label our data if we don't know that
I also anomalies may be different in the
future so even if they do tell you that
doesn't mean that's the same animal is
gonna occur again
however we are saying that some shape
characteristics should be respected and
this is actually the fact of an anomaly
what I'm showing here because I don't
know if you can see it there but there
is a little bit of a different contrast
that's an artery that's going through
the gland and the technologists decided
to contour that out so this is not part
of the gland I'm gonna put it out but
this actually was wrong because you need
to include the arteries and this was a
contrast agent that was giving this this
difference and if you think about then
it's interesting because then you can do
some feature engineering it's okay if
they do that then I can maybe define an
index which will be lets say concavity
index so whenever they try to do
something that's concavity index my my
algorithm pick it up in the same manner
you can build more of these features
such as symmetry of a shape perimeter
over area simple stuff things are we can
explain easily also in the clinic and
there's a nice library in Python that
was I think originally built for
topological problems that's called
shapely if you are if you have similar
data I recommend I suggest that you have
a look on this so this was a good
starting point that we can easily
extract these features the other thing
that we yeah so going to the modeling
now part one of the most common
anomaly vector machine learning
algorithms that are around and they are
in the psychic learner actually library
is the isolation forest which is an
unsupervised learning technique and in a
nutshell what it's a decision tree
basically this is a random forest
approach in which K with a twist though
the twist here is that basically when
you're trying to do a split on your
feature space on it and a feature you do
a random split uniformly between a
minute maximum value and then you
continue doing that until all your
samples are completely isolated and the
idea is very simple that if you had very
difficulties isolating a point like in
the case of the graph on the left that
probably indicates that the point is not
really and I normally well if you can
easily separate it and isolate it so
that means in the tree that it was
actually shorter the depth of the tree
that you have to go until you you
isolate that point that is an indication
it might be an outlier but again we do
need labels as in any data science
project and we do not have label data
most of the things in the hospital you
do not have label data so what can we do
about that two approaches the one would
be either you generate then anomalies
you can use some type of perturbation
all the features that you have but this
might not be realistic enough you might
use distributions that they might not be
accurate we have explored this by using
some one atomically decreasing functions
with the assumption that anomaly is
probably going to be less likely to be a
huge anomaly than a small anomaly the
other approach would be to have a domain
expert the clinician that is gonna label
for us this is also very difficult
because labor intensive they don't have
that much time to do that for you and
then secondly also they don't know what
an anomaly is going back to that
original question so you can ask you how
I'm gonna do that and then a third one
they're also going to be biased so
they're gonna basically create the
anomalies that they think but in reality
this would have been something better so
this is another approach that you can do
and from our experience trying to follow
the best machine learning practice but
also be pragmatic we found that it's not
really that we're not really talking
about a data-driven approach we're
mostly talking about data-driven and
expert driven approach so we we start
with training and testing a model just
to get going we run the model as it is
if it's not perfect but we let it run in
the clinic and the expert checks and
then the expert sort of in this stage
learns also what do you model is doing
it gets a little bit excited hopefully
and then you can also help you with
labeling Future anomalies and then you
do your future engineering and you go
through another circle this where
hopefully you're gonna have now the
expert generating anomalies for you that
you can do a little bit more serious
validation test and you do
regularization and then this can be and
then as you can imagine give me an
everlasting process obviously but this
is a realistic way to tap into how to
have label data the other area also so
even if you do that and the clinician
then one's gonna come and tell you okay
you are going to let's say says that
this X data point wasn't normally why so
it's very crucial because we're talking
about patient data here and you're
basically saying that there's a medical
problem so these are heavy words say in
a hospital so you have to explain
yourself
and we don't know but there are
libraries out there that they can help
you with that and one of the libraries
is called skater that we're using and
others also another library is doing
something similar which basically
they're this is sort of a meta model on
your prediction results in which case
they can highlight what exactly would be
the what where exactly the features that
were higher they were really anomalous
and in this case all the green bars are
basically the features that were
positive as anomalies so green would be
bad in this graph and you can also see
some range of values of what this
features had for example the first two
cases here first two features were
actually the lengths of the structures
and this is very useful information
every day for the clinic because the
claim can
we get a better insight of what they
were actually doing all these years
even if you pass all the stairs steps
you you still have to build a pipeline
in a hospital and I wanted to spend a
little bit time on that because it's not
very trivial to do that in a hospital
yeah ideally you want to have a database
of structured data label data let's say
and then you can split your data do a
trained test and run it's a server and a
cloud and then deploy it again a server
cloud
similarly the reality that we see looks
more like this we we do not have really
a data base they are some data bases but
they're very vendor specific because
hospitals were cloud commercial software
and they have their own databases which
you're not you cannot tap into that we
do have other data warehouses where we
have this DICOM image protocol which at
least we have the same formatting in our
data that is say so we have to spend a
lot of time and luckily we had a very
talented that engineer in our team that
can help us make these processes to
extract this data but even after this
step this data are nested data graph
based data meaning that I cannot really
say bring me a patient that had this
city I cannot say that I have to find on
each patient go to see did he got a
treatment he got a plan did he did he
get some imaging if you get some imagery
I have to go all the images so this
actually led us to a decision to build
an RDF database not sure how many of you
have are using RDF database or no
they're not the most common but the end
you have to use a sparkle as a query
language which is a bit peculiar but we
had to do that first step and then
another problem is that when we're
talking about servers in clinics okay
you cannot put anything the cloud that's
out of the option because these are
sensitive data you can't even use most
of the servers that are in the clinic
because these are dedicated for the
clinic so then they would ask you are
you doing research or a clinic should be
doing research there's a cluster but
this is the problem now with that
data science sort of like has one like
on a different boat let's say like so
we're trying to balance between these
two things so me for example technically
I'm not allowed to see a lot of the
patient data so this causes a lot of
problems our approach to this was from
that sparkle queries we created a sequel
database that would be fast because
sparkle is also slow for our data for
our projects then we have modules to
create the labels which based on the
process that I've mentioned before and
with the services we still have ongoing
discussions with hospital to try to have
a dedicated server for data science
projects so all these that might be
trivial in other cases in in our case we
have to fight for them yeah in the
previous step another thing the previous
speaker also mentioned that how
important visualization in la analytics
when your models are and we also had the
same experience clinical clinicians are
not gonna like probably running
something on a command line or they want
to see something nice it gives sort of a
credibility to what you're doing even
but but it's nice to see things in a
nice format and that's what they want to
see at the end so we put a lot of effort
at all so you have like nice dashboards
for them from the prediction database so
they can and this also was good because
the clinicians you don't want them to
put - bring them in the same team with
you
- feel that they're building something
with you so you're not competing with
them and in that case for example in
this case it's like a time series of the
anomalies that were picked and the Reds
would show what if it was a normal green
it would be not anomaly and if you click
it it would give you also some feature
importance metrics so simple things like
that that they can can help us he helped
the team asked you understand better how
the model behaves but also the clinician
gets a little bit more data excited with
the data yeah so at the end I wanted
also to
to spend a little bit time now to some
of the results without really going
through accuracy metrics just to have
some icon this year of cases that we
picked up that were very interested in
my case so all these are anomalies this
is all from our models and the model is
now running in the clinic in parallel to
the clinical workflow so on the Left we
see basically one slice of square shape
that's an error there was a reason why
that happened
so there was no compromise in the
treatments as you say but this error
what was what I found interesting is
that if you look on the bottom the
future importance indeed gives you that
okay there was a whole bunch of features
here that were kind of exploded it's
very clear that this was an anomaly on
the second case it was not an error and
this is again the case of a gland that
you can see goes like really far and
then when we went to the expert to ask
him what's happening in this case he
actually told us okay this is not really
the gland this is sort of a dock that
goes from the gland in the mouth and we
don't really know if this is part of our
structure or not some people do this
some people don't do this so that's
that's very interesting for me because
that means that basically my problem was
not anomaly detection it was basically
consensus agreement like do we is the
team is doing reproducibly what we think
they're doing and the other interesting
thing is that the future explanation
also sort of had a borderline opinion
like some features are green some
features are red a third category of
anomalies are cases now that the shape
was really anomalous so it was clear
there was an anomaly but another factor
that we didn't think of was that people
that have head and neck cancers they
often go through surgeries so they might
have some of formation in the shape of
their body contour or they might have
this by ear which means basically they
cannot eat well so they might get
thinner so the anatomy changed through
their treatment and this result in a
normal shape but it was not really an
error it was actually how the patient's
body was changing so this actually could
be used also to see how
patience body was changing so some final
remarks and maybe some questions that
raised to this this process about
building a data science
pipeline in the clinic first of all the
anomaly detector I think it's a very
exciting area of machine learning for
hospitals that's basically in hospitals
what most people do they're trying to
find anomalies and it can be used in
many cases I believe like lab results
quality assurance checks emergency room
but as patrick said in the hospitals we
don't really have data science yet we do
have a lot of data but some of the
reasons why data science is challenging
is that we do not have yet data science
infrastructure in place that's something
we're struggling and I think in our
Institute we're very lucky because they
are pushing towards that and that's how
they why they build the data science
team outsourcing will also be
challenging especially now with gdpr
is not gonna be easy to hire somebody to
look at patient data and so that's also
so my thoughts here is that probably
Hospital have to really start building
their teams from within not outsourcing
also how can we involve more the domain
experts in the conversation
avoiding the language of you're going to
be replaced in five years by an
algorithm and yeah and also how now on
the other side how can we attract more
data so in people in the hospitals so
this is also very important so these two
worlds can meet well thank you
I have a very specific question about
the lime explainers that you had on the
previous slide if you want to go back to
them for a sec and I don't know that
there's a right or wrong answer here
it's just I'm seeing a lot of
observations here that I've empirically
seen while using lime as well and the
first is a the the values on the
coefficients are often very close to
zero so I'm wondering how you have
confidence that these are meaningful
explanations as opposed to just noise
because this is something I've
encountered as well and on the other
question I have is I know empirically
lime has been shown to be very unstable
for very similar expansion so do you
ever come across a situation where like
two strands that are very similar
yeah but explanations are dramatically
different yeah how much time to get but
you're right lime we've noticed by that
it's not very stable you're right
sometimes we run even the same patient
and it gives us a little bit different
results so there are some thoughts there
one thought is if you want to have some
type of analysis and this you can just
run it ten times let's say and you have
like some been range of what was the
variation of your future importance but
at the first stage we just wanted to
have like a quick visual view so we're
not peculiar very peak yet about that
aspect but you right and there is
another library that I want to try a
shop that I saw that some people are
using which from what I understand is
linked with lime but anyway we're going
to explore both cases we don't really
have a Nokia strong opinion in this yet
thanks Patrick and Pavlik thank you
there's another
thank you great talk to what extent are
there other teams around the world
working on similar problems do you know
about them are you able to coordinate
with them are you able to share perhaps
anonymized data because obviously this
is a sort of field where the more data
you have the better in terms of
extracting meaningful results yes
sharing patient data is among different
hospitals is still very difficult life
from what we've seen in general it's not
really a way that has been a way that
has been put in place one thing I know
that in the Netherlands they tried was
to share the model so that's another way
that is being discussed which might be
safer yes and and then there are some
initiatives there are more local
initiatives to start building data
science team so this I think is really
we're in the early phase of this we're
that's my feeling but we are catching up
and it's it's a lot of still in research
phase so we're trying to really work
towards a clinical implementation which
will actually be used by a clinician
that's also it's I think we're catching
up now in what we're doing looking at
the questions were hidden a lot of the
medical research and I have seen has
been imaging Auguste has been
understanding scans are you aware of
anybody doing research going into other
areas like interpretation of blood test
results or attempting to do much by the
way of natural language understanding of
the more freeform data sources good
question
no I'm not really aware of it but but
there's also since we just started we
also we just started talking to
conditions let's put it that way so we
also need to explore the field because
we are literal radiotherapy and it's
sort of maybe limiting us so we need to
also we need to broaden our view as well
but I'm not aware of these applications
but I'm sure that they might be very
useful yes indeed but a you write
natural like for example consultation
it's mostly text so that's that's and
it's it's a number the first step of
this process you would expect we're
going to do that first in some hospitals
it's still it's not they're not always
also electronically these consultations
you haven't yet had a chance to explore
you're looking at any part of the
history to go to add to the scans for
example to aid the interpretation at
this stage you need to look at you know
the clinical the clinical presentation
and the symptoms the people who going as
well as the scans to to enhance that
data set it's not something you had a
chance to look at yet to enhance the
data so like that augmentation you mean
on the images no just you know using
data other than the images to say how
does how was the patient feeling or no
we haven't we haven't what yeah yeah
these are very good valid points they
sort of feel like it obvious is the
first steps but what are you describing
also about outcome and toxicity like a
patient having a knob saying that I
started feeling not by giving us some
metrics of how he feels from this
they're not many places in the world
that they they keep track of the patient
but that's again dr. by doctor and and
this is this is a nice area of high very
good talk you you talk about the the
challenge of having missing sort of data
savvy people in the clinical world what
about trying to bridge the gap from the
other side so sort of having clinical
savvy see the people it's not we we are
the clinical we are
yeah yeah good question well I mean it's
a good question a clinical data that's
the best thing right you have the darker
that right - but but that does not exist
easily right because they go through a
very very different training and they
have to learn a lot of things and they
have also a job like nobody's gonna quit
their job as a doctor to become a data
scientist so it's it's difficult it's
not as easy as in other fields that we
see but it would be very nice to you but
there are some doctors are right - male
do you back in the physics and most
people aren't a science will have
physics engineering background do we not
need new ideas today with medicine where
what I feel like affects the cleaning
outcomes what my feelings are with my
chemistry is humans are not biological
system dynamical systems physics is very
simple to do with a more holistic
approach so what yeah it's a complex
system yes but we're a very simple
thinker so we need to we need to yes
you're I think your apps would be right
and I'm not sure if there's any it's
very compartmentalized medical
healthcare still yeah I don't know it's
a valid approach but yeah but but you
need to start somewhere
and these we started here but things
should get bigger and more inclusive yes
indeed institutional context for doing
medical data science because I'm struck
that the brilliant work that you have
done will improve outcomes perhaps at
your house
what about the hospitals in France or
some hospitals in Canada because I'm
struck by the fact that when a
pharmaceutical company develops a new
drug it is potentially can be licensed
throughout the world similarly for a
medical device but yet because of the
way your system is deployed it doesn't
seem to have the same global reach now
there is a global you just I don't I
don't agree the global reach starts with
the talk in high data to begin with and
then you give incentive to people to get
in there and then this other question is
that
I mean it's about point where you're
saying it's true it's just that we were
trying to change this and show a pardon
from within the hospital with the
pharmaceutical Isis that you said one
solution some hospitals they the biggest
hospitals in order to avoid being so
much charge about pharmaceutical have
brands was they build their own
pharmacies so that's that's how we
should do it data science I think
hostage should be their own data science
teams and then they talk to each other
they have meetings and they grow maybe
yeah thank you for the toy it's very
interesting I think I can really
appreciate the difficulty that you have
that's almost you've got 101 problems
that stop you from really having the
effect that I think some of the people
have into that I'm thinking of the NHS
digital equivalent in the UK where
actually a lot of what's stopping you at
the moment is not really anything you
can do in your remit in your in the
situation you're in but it's almost yeah
how much the local government can help
you expand this out I'm just wondering
to what point do you think that you're
soon gonna reach a blocker where there's
only so far you can go before you've got
buy-in from the government to really
expand the remit of where you can go
with this sort of public yes so I guess
there's always more hospitals that you
can run these Charles on there's always
more that you can try and test and
there's always more
yeah implement you can run for so do you
need that now do you need that you can
you if you've got a lot more of them to
go for in their area that you've got
right now I'm just wondering where does
it become a government like a regional
government problem more than problem
that you're working on right now well
the government's and they do see that
like there's a lot of talking about out
of science so the hope is that there
will be I think the end goal would be
you have specialized people working in
data science problems in the hospital or
they managed to do something with this
data protection rules so the outsource
so you have some sort of collaboration
of the government to companies I'm not
sure if that's gonna happen easily but
the hope is that the government's will
start seeing the need for this but they
have we're trying to prove an example of
something that would be exactly yes you
guys is almost a POC which is that the
government see this they see the concept
they see the value of it and yeah I'm
guessing I'm wondering what the feedback
you've got from government said if they
recognize that this is a good PA see
that they don't approach yeah
have a good answers we haven't done too
much strategic thinking that's yet maybe
very point
thanks for questions please bring others
of line
[Music]
[Applause]